hey everyone i am back for yet another
video and today's is going to be about
ryak a distributed key value store if
you asked my ex-girlfriend she would say
that me in this video have a lot in
common in the sense that the video is
not going to be particularly interesting
and it certainly is not going to last
very long that being said it's important
that we cover ryak because it seems to
have come up a decent amount in my
personal studying as a data system that
a decent amount of companies will use
and so as a result i'm going to go over
it pretty quickly all righty so ryak
what is it
ryak is yet another distributed database
system that tries to achieve really high
read and write throughput it has a ton
of similarities to cassandra which i've
covered in the past in terms of both the
replication the partitioning the actual
rate engine and i've covered those all
previously so if you haven't watched
that video i'd recommend just watching
the cassandra video and then this video
will make a lot more sense but it just
mainly seems the most reasonable to
discuss kind of the differences between
ryak and cassandra because that's what
makes riak a little bit useful
and there are really only two main ones
so we'll go ahead and talk about those
now
okay so in terms of data modeling like i
mentioned in the past cassandra is a
wide column store which means that you
have this concept of a row key and then
you have any amount of column keys
attached to that
which have values and
you can also have this concept of
clustering keys which within a partition
and partitions are kind of delineated by
that range of row key
the clustering keys help determine the
sort order on the other hand riac is
really just a key value store which
means that all you really have is key
and some value where the value can
basically be anything that means it
could be a blob which is kind of like a
file it could be json it could just be a
string or a number or anything along
those lines so it means that in theory
you could probably store something a
little bit more complex like you know a
huge json document with you know tons of
lists in that or even nested things or
an image but at the same time
it means that you're probably not really
going to have great secondary index
capabilities and querying based off
things in the actual value itself you
can do this
using something called the secondary
index in riac but generally it seems not
very efficient because every single
key value pair will have to have this
extra metadata now that enables you to
search by the secondary index
you can also integrate your riot keys
and values with um a ryac search index
which is something i'll discuss in the
future but um for now it the point is
that natively ray key value um you know
it's mainly just if you want to be able
to search on keys
okay what about conflict resolution
because this is the other kind of
important area so if you recall
both ryak and cassandra are using a
dynamo-style implementation which means
that all writes are not going to one
liter node but rather they can pretty
much go to any single node in the
cluster that's going to be handling that
partition
and that node can accept that right so
inevitably what's going to happen is
there will be race conditions and there
will be right conflicts
as for how cassandra deals with this
they use last right wins so basically
each right once it reaches the server is
assigned a timestamp and the right
ultimately with the higher timestamp is
the one that's kept there are two issues
with this the first is that timestamps
are unreliable so those servers might be
out of sync and so the wrong write may
win and then the second one
is that what happens with the right that
basically came in a millisecond before
well it's just lost no one even hears of
it no one knows why it's lost it's just
gone
so how does riak go and try and fix this
well they use something called version
vectors version vectors are a topic that
i touched upon way back earlier on the
channel
in the multi-leader replication video
but the point is version vectors are
just a good way of keeping track of kind
of what a client uh has known about was
in the database whenever they made a
write and by doing so you can kind of
keep track of the dependencies of a
write and see if two rights for the same
object were causally related as in
one was done knowing about the other or
if they were concurrent one was done
without knowing about the other and if
they're concurrent what you go ahead and
do is actually store them as siblings
and once two rights are stored as
siblings it means that anyone reading
from the database
in the future will receive both of those
siblings as a read and go ahead and try
to merge them in the application code so
in our back end for example we would be
writing extra code to handle the fact
that there may be siblings on a read and
then we would merge those in one way or
another as we see fit and put them back
in the database
but what if for example you don't
actually want to deal with the merging
and say you just want something that
works pretty seamlessly like a counter
or a set or a map well fortunately we
talked about that in the last video and
that's called a crdt a conflict-free
replicated data type which is just any
sort of data structure that you can kind
of have multiple sources of rights for
and eventually they will converge to the
same state so some examples of this that
ryak has are counters sets and maps and
as a result if we don't want to be
writing custom application code in order
to kind of handle the fact that there
may be siblings in the database using
something like a crdt allows us to have
the database kind of handle those
discrepancies itself and deal with the
conflicts automatically which is super
useful
okay so in conclusion ryak is another
super high throughput database however
it only is really high throughput for
single key reads and writes
things like range scans over a certain
you know primary key but a given
clustering key as woodwork and cassandra
don't really work that way that being
said if you actually look at the
internals of ryak and cassandra they
look super similar they're both dealing
with the same type of parquet
partitioning schema via consistent
hashing on a key the same type of
multi-master replication
lsm trees and reed repair and entropy so
that's how they're able to achieve that
high right throughput
but unlike cassandra like i said ryak
gives you a little bit more flexibility
in terms of how you store your data
simply because the value can literally
be anything
but it comes at the cost of the fact
that since it's only a key value store
doing things like sorting within a
partition are not very easy and it
requires you to either add extra
metadata for a secondary index or
integrate some extra search index
technology to work with your data
and then compared to cassandra kind of
the main benefits of using ryak are like
i said greater flexibility in data
storage due to values
and additionally the fact that if you
have conflicting rights we're no longer
using last right wins which is kind of
one of the biggest pitfalls of cassandra
it's kind of like the easy way out for
dealing with right conflicts and instead
what ryack will let you
allow you to do is basically deal with
siblings in a database and merge those
in any way you see fit or if you don't
want to do that merge them automatically
in the databases themselves using crdts
okay guys i hope this video was helpful
like i said it was going to be a pretty
short one but the good thing is that now
that we've touched on this key value
store we can start talking about
in-memory key value stores and dealing
with caching